[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pierre niney pour votre plage de
tiergues et
jeanine et pierre minet qui est aussi
nommé pour boîtes noires ce soir je
révisais j'ai mon truc pareil il est
nommé
bernard minet non à mauborget lellouche
une fiente on y est presque ça
s'approche oui l'astronef un peu
sans les mains oui bah voilà
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bouffé à écouter le message de mme
agnès il ya 15 ans qui a ramené vous de
saint valentin écoute
[Musique]
or on va lui répondre de suite alors
ma chère nièce comme cadeau je pense que
tu pourrais lui offrir le code pénal
je peux fait de gros bisous et passe une
belle paris
[Musique]
ceci à qui vous inspire ben un guetteur
seront moins soit nous qui
supportent seuls le kick
back et de position
[Musique]
[Rires]